palace overnight before being moved to
westminster hall for the lying in state
in london that's all
for this hour and a botting and i will
be back it's with sky news at 10 coming
up next trevor phillips is here with a
royal special programme
good evening from buckingham palace i'm
trevor phillips and welcome to a sky
news royal special on the death of the
queen
coming up in the next hour
together in grief the queen's children
keeping a vigil over her in saint
giles's cathedral
tonight the public's first chance to pay
personal respects
filing past the queen's coffin
all this after the solemn procession of
the late queen through the streets of
edinburgh to her first lying at rest
[Applause]
[Music]
a service of thanksgiving for a monarch
who loved scotland in the heart of its
capital
[Music]
he's feeling the weight of history the
message from king charles to mps and
members of the house of lords in an
historic westminster address
and the right to protest versus dignity
and respect
should police be arresting people
disrupting the royal events
good evening and welcome to buckingham
palace for a royal special on the death
of the queen
today a more somber tone as the twin
processes of mourning for the sovereign
past and recognition of the sovereign
present
gather pace
but i think we're beginning to see the
shape of this new monarchy
and it looks remarkably familiar
the king this morning emphasized an
emerging theme in his speech to the
houses of parliament when he quoted
shakespeare calling his mother a pattern
for all princes
it is no accident that the words from
the play henry viii describes the
newborn elizabeth the first the king
who's no stranger to the stage is
telling us i think that this is the
continuity monarchy
in the next hour we'll reflect on the
day's events and what they might mean
but the king was in edinburgh this
evening and has taken part in a vigil
over the late queen's coffin at sinjar's
cathedral with his brothers and sister
and a family grief and proximity to
their mother is being shared as i speak
by members of the public who are
processing past the coffin and paying
their respects to the woman for her
lifetime of service to the nation
james matthews has our first report on
the queen lying at rest
this was the scene inside saint giles
cathedral as the day drew to a close
the queen lay at rest and her four
children mounted a vigil around her
coffin
these were live television pictures of a
most significant state event
it was a public illustration
of a family's private grief
[Music]
this was the palace of holyrood house
earlier in the day
[Music]
through time history has been shaped in
this corner of edinburgh's altar
this was how it looked for a monarch and
a mother lost
the queen's coffin was driven up the
city's royal mile for a service of
thanksgiving
her children walked with her
this was a picture of a sovereign past
and present
in one frame it was a family's grief and
the nation's chain
the root was lined by several thousand
people in a shared ritual of remembrance
and to record history
a day to offer condolences and to bear
witness
god bless the queen
there were isolated shouts as the
procession passed by the canon gate cook
where the queen used to attend sunday
service
her family had gathered privately in the
immediate wake of her passing the
journey south the day before had invited
wider society to share its feelings so
did this
there was some applause but this large
crowd shared its sentiment
powerfully in its silence
the calm was only punctured by guns
fired in tribute at edinburgh castle as
the city beneath paid its respect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in sinjar's cathedral it was a service
to give thanks
the prime minister had traveled north to
join a congregation drawn from across
scottish society
and politics for everything there is a
season
and a time for every matter under heaven
a time to be born and a time to die
here at the cathedral in the heart of
scotland's capital they remembered the
queen they knew here much has been said
about the queen's contribution to the
life of the united kingdom
and the commonwealth
which meant so much to her
but here in scotland we acknowledge with
gratitude her deep links with our land
and its people
her love of the balmoral estate
is well known
and being there laterally
brought her great comfort
there she was valued as a neighbor
and a friend
and there she drew strength
and refreshment during the summer months
following the service of thanksgiving
the royal company of archers moved
forward the traditional bodyguard with
one final duty to watch over their queen
at rest
here she had been among people who knew
her some who'd been with her in her
final days
she she might have wondered do you vote
have this
or she may want to do the thing the role
that i played did not have any effect on
how people
view me because they see me as part of
the institution or whatever
i think yesterday and today has shown
that there was it was more than simply
respect there is there was a genuine
affection
back at the palace of holyrood house the
royal standard of scotland was raised
full mast the first time here for the uk
as in giles the public waited for hours
to pay their respects to the queen as
she lay at rest the queue snake through
the streets of central edinburgh
for a period some were joined by her
children
the loss of a queen is a significant
moment in history
these pictures showed a family taking a
moment for themselves and their mother
and their loss
was laid there
matthews sky news edinburgh
we're joined by our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills good evening rhiannon um
you and i spoken uh several times this
weekend about
the balance that is being struck here
between
a state event
and a familial event and i i've heard
you talking about that today again and
james has just mentioned it uh do you
think they're managing that
these are
four children who all individually
throughout their lives have talked about
what fantastic training they had
from both the queen and the duke of
edinburgh when it came to
performing those public duties
realizing that they would constantly
have a life punctuated by the kind of
processions that we've seen today having
to appear in public
and yet as you looked at the pictures
that we saw today you cannot help but
think just how much it took for for all
of them to rally themselves
and appear in front of the crowds in the
way that they did and it happened really
on on two occasions didn't it so the
first
when we saw the
the coffin
leaving the palace of hollyrood house
the queen
leaving
her official scottish residence
for the last time
and what struck me was it was the first
time that we'd seen the new king
and the queen in her coffin
in such close proximity and
king charles did seem to have to take a
breath
and
rally himself little before then
stepping off also the fact that all four
siblings were standing alongside each
other shoulder to shoulder as they made
that very slow walk up towards saint
giles's cathedral
um yes one of them has had to as he's
described it step up and take on the
heaviest of responsibilities but
ultimately they were all sharing in this
this moment of grief and then to see
them again return to saint john's
cathedral and it's been described so
often this afternoon as them publicly
sharing their own private morning you
can only imagine what they were thinking
as for 20 minutes their heads were bowed
all of them lost in their own thoughts
um
on a day where we know that it's been
incredibly busy again for king charles
um and yet to stand and basically be
there in front of members of the public
because i didn't expect this but still
the public were being allowed to
move through saint john's cathedral as
the four members of the royal family
were standing there and that procession
of members of the public is is
continuing this evening inside st giles
cathedral
on a day where just as they did
throughout her life and certainly in the
last 12 months and now in her death they
have been there very naturally
supporting their mother the queen
and it is very striking i mean one of
the things that i was particularly
surprised by the sheer physicality of
their day today i mean anybody who has
walked up the royal mile knows that
up has a real meaning in that walk and
um you know two of these uh the four
children are over 70 uh i haven't got
there yet but i'm not sure i could do it
as
with their fortitude i mean it has been
an extraordinarily
tough day i guess for them
yeah it was the first thing that i
thought of this morning was again we're
seeing the pace of all of this it's all
happening so quickly isn't it if you
think it was only thursday when the
queen's death was announced we're only
on monday now and the king and his queen
consort the king who's 73 the queen
consort who's 75 crammed in
seven different engagements if you like
seven different ceremonial events within
that one day now we know they have this
incredible work ethic whatever people
think about the once prince of wales and
now king charles you cannot doubt his
real commitment when it comes to
powering on with those duties but yeah
it i think what we are seeing as the
days unfold again just as we saw
yesterday with the the car making that
travel traveling through scotland today
again we had
a moment to at least pause
and reflect and that's what we're seeing
as as we move towards the funeral of
course that's going to take place on
monday
and we heard um in his uh speech in
the houses of parliament this morning
and i think i detected a note of this
again
uh in his speech at holyrood a sort of
reassurance that
his model really is his mother and
whatever you think about what he might
have been and done in the past
that if we want to know what sort of
king he's going to be we need to look at
what sort of queen she was
in every speech that he's made i think
he has
tried to clear up some of the questions
that we might have
quite subtly but clear up questions
about what kind of monarch he's going to
be
and it was particularly striking when we
heard his first address to the nation
and i think you're right i think we
heard it again in the the westminster
hall and then here at the scottish
parliament that sense of
i do
fully respect the political institutions
i do respect that sense of political
neutrality which i must now uphold of
course over the years there's been so
much discussion about whether or not he
would be
that phrase a meddling monarch when he
was 70 he tried to put up to bed saying
look i know that i can't be that man
anymore i think he's trying to cement
that in our minds it was phrased to me
once by one of his very close advisors
when you're monarch you have to be when
you're air you have to do if there's air
you're not doing anything people will
question what you're doing and that is
why i think we saw him as this crusading
prince he wanted to make a difference
throughout those 70 years
now he realizes that it's time to step
back focus
on those constitutional responsibilities
but we wait to see how exactly that's
going to to pan out
when we get through what is undoubtedly
a very difficult 10 days for him where
we keep being reminded the most
important role for him is to lead the
country lead his family
in this moment of
mourning rhiannon thank you i think
we'll speak again a bit later now
with me to talk through this evening's
events in edinburgh is tracy borman
royal historian and author of crown
and scepter um now tracy what uh i think
has been let's start with the queen
herself you studied these transitions um
has the
emotion the public affection
surprised you or is that par for the
course for this
moment in a monarch's life
or death i should say yeah i don't think
it's surprising because i think all of
the opinion polls throughout the late
queen's reign showed that she was held
in huge regard even by hardened
republicans they still respected the
queen but i think what is surprising is
the sheer volume that we're seeing you
know the crowds descending here on
london and also up in edinburgh and
there's talk of a 14 kilometer queue
here for the for the lying in state and
it's just remarkable so
the the theme in the latter years of the
queen's reign is that people generally
were more passive about the monarchy
they didn't turn up in such great
numbers as they once did i think we're
proving that wrong now
we um hear a lot about her longevity we
know we've heard about her scent of
human and i said her personality um
but what would you pick out as being
besides the length of her reign
especially about her particular uh
period
well i think we will look back on that
abiding sense of duty and that was
instilled in her by her father george vi
who wasn't supposed to be king it was
only thanks to his brother's abdication
and he was probably one of the most
reluctant kings in british history but
he did his duty and he certainly
instilled that same sense of duty in his
daughter but in terms of legacy i would
say you know the queen wasn't just a a
safe pair of hands and a traditionalist
she did revolutionize in a a fairly
quiet way but one of the biggest things
that she left behind was a change in law
in terms of the succession and for the
first time we have equality in the royal
succession thanks to the late queen so
that female heirs have equal precedence
with male heirs and i can tell you that
is huge in the thousand or more history
of the british monarchy it's taken that
long but that's elizabeth ii's legacy
that's true because actually the prince
of the now prince of wales's children
would not all have been uh
in line i think princess charlotte would
have had to stand behind
her brothers and indeed maybe uh
prince harry if i remember right in the
old system but now she's
on the same standing as her brothers
absolutely so um that that is a big
change now the irony is that the
likelihood is that we just have a
succession of kings for the foreseeable
future anyway but yes uh charlotte takes
her place and she wouldn't have done
that had it not been for the queen it is
interesting isn't it because uh what we
hear a lot about is a queen as um
a symbol of continuity
but from what you say actually
what is true in 2022 might not have been
imagined as possible in 1952. absolutely
so what caused huge shock waves when the
queen came to the throne
was the fact that she chose to have her
coronation televised now that was huge
you can imagine the resistance among the
very traditional royal establishment but
she pushed through with this decision
and it was seen as completely radical of
course now
everything's televised news goes around
the globe in seconds um and we're seeing
more things uh televised under the reign
of king charles iii already the
accession and so forth so there has been
huge change along the way and i think
the queen personally has been
responsible for
bringing the royal family you know into
the the modern era so she still upheld
traditions but she made sure it was
still in touch all right well we'll look
forward to the new king's style in a
moment
but let's stay with today in between
those actions of public ceremony to
honor his mother the king had a
significant day in the political realm
this morning he addressed both houses of
parliament at westminster hall promising
to uphold the constitutional conditions
under which parliament sits
while expressing his gratitude for the
messages of condolences
and this evening he was present in
hollywood to hear a motion of condolence
from the scottish parliament
our political editor beth rigby reports
now on a day of constitutional ceremony
for the new king
sounding a fanfare for the new king
westminster hall home to much of our
nation's history from medieval to modern
times
but few occasions compare with this the
second elizabethan age is over
parliament welcoming a new monarch and a
new reign
past prime ministers and
parliamentarians here to pay their
respects and to offer the new king
addresses of condolence led by the
speakers of each parliamentary house
deeper grief is
we know yours is deeper
we offer our heartfelt sympathy to you
and all the royal family
whatever his private grief the king here
for a very public and performative event
his fast speech to parliament meeting
the enormity of that moment
i cannot help but feel the weight
of history
which surrounds us
and which reminds us
of the vital parliamentary traditions
to which members of both houses
dedicate yourselves
a hereditary monarchy renewing its
commitment to parliamentary democracy
parliament
is the living and breathing instrument
of our democracy
that your traditions
are ancient
we stay
in the construction of this great
hall and the reminders of medieval
predecessors
of the office
to which i have been called
while very young
her late majesty
pledged herself
to serve her country
and her people
and to maintain the precious principles
of constitutional government
which lie at the heart
of our nation
this vow she kept
with unsurpassed devotion
she set an example
of selfless duty
which
with god's help
and your councils
i am resolved faithfully to follow
the national anthem now sung for him the
emotion of this moment plain to see
this ceremony concluded the king and
queen consort now leaving westminster
for hollywood
and a deep breath in for a monarch not
only mourning his mother but trying to
reassure a nation too
[Applause]
[Music]
the king embarking now on a nationwide
tour leaving this legislature in london
and landing just a couple of hours later
in scotland to address another
arriving at the scottish parliament and
setting aside his ceremonial uniform for
the kilt
two minutes of silence and heads bowed
before the king addressed the
politicians and people of scotland
my mother felt as i do the
greatest admiration for the scottish
people
for their magnificent achievements
and their indomitable spirit
and it was the greatest comfort for her
to know in turn
the true affection
in which she was held
[Music]
two nations in one day this a king well
aware of the task he faces leading a
country from one era to another an
unfamiliar and difficult journey for all
beth rigby sky news westminster
tracy borman is with me once more tracy
um
am i over interpreting to call this the
continuity monarchy i think that's
absolutely spot on and many times in the
long history of the crown people have
predicted disaster with a change of rain
it's a very destabilizing time and
certainly that was the case with
elizabeth ii who was immensely popular
of course she was our longest reigning
monarch so i think people expected the
monarchy would almost fall
at her death and what we've seen is a
very smooth transition and that tends to
be the case throughout history the
apparatus of monarchy gets going and
that's what it's designed to do
to ensure a smooth succession from one
monarch to the next monarch
do you think that um there is anything
particular that is uh emerging all from
the king as a as we've seen he's
stressing this point and rhiannon made
this this point that
don't look for anything very different
but
as we've already been seeing it's much
more open the accession
uh
council being on television i was
reflecting that
there's literally nobody
alive
who had seen what we all saw on saturday
morning and isn't that extraordinary it
has felt the past few days like we're
watching history take shape before our
eyes it is you know quite amazing um and
i think we will see changes perhaps more
subtle than had been predicted and
you're absolutely right in that king
charles has been stressing uh time and
again that he's going to
uphold the status quo it's business as
usual he referred to uh there in the
footage of the weight of history and i
think he certainly feels that and he
must recognize um what it was people
valued and respected about the late
queen and i think he will seek to
emulate that but i you know it's not
just going to be business as usual he's
going to have his own views on things
and his own stamp on the monarchy and
everybody who thinks that there's value
in history and you know we're both in
that camp i should think um
we'll say
let's look back at parallels to learn
and if they were if they'd been looking
back in parallel
of these sorts of transitions
what would they have been looked at
looking at and thinking we want to avoid
that again
well i was going to say particularly a
topical transition um for today is that
from the tudors to the stuarts so with
the death of the first elizabeth in 1603
uh she was the virgin queen she had no
children the throne passed to james of
scotland now that is when really
everybody was predicting some kind of
revolution but the new king king came in
it was said not a mouse stirred and uh
and he took the throne and it was all
remarkably smooth he became well james
six of scotland to james the first of
england and scotland exactly and that's
why we have a united kind of crown today
it took a few years for that to be
confirmed by parliament um and actually
in nearly every case it's a very very
smooth transition so um really we're
seeing history repeat itself
okay let's uh let's see where this goes
now
thousands of people uh gathered today uh
in edinburgh
massing on the streets as the queen's
coffin was taken in solemn procession
from hollywood house to saint giles
greg mullen has been speaking to those
paying their respects
you order it from two then ace then kang
then queen
some had waited all night a patient
reflective audience to see a moment of
history
but also just to say goodbye
old and young they lined the street they
even brought their
making new friendships among strangers
brought together in a moment of mourning
i gotta say my goodbye
just
heartbroken
heartbroken
never ever ever
ever see this again that's the duke of
edinburgh that i got from prince philip
that's promise i made to serve the queen
for many this grief is very real
my mum was born the same year as the
queen and she had a sister
and she went through the war years guide
to see rangers all the same time as the
queen and she died in february so i just
felt it was sort of great that i should
come
not just for the queen but for my mum
whether they simply watched or whether
they filmed the power of this moment was
palpable
she was our touchstone
touchstone for us and for the world
i think it's remarkable for a divided
country to come together like this
she's
a one-off
it's a moment in history in a moment in
time and
the queen means so much to everybody in
scotland
it's just a yeah a very poignant
day for everybody
i think whenever you get down into
westminster london it'll be multiplying
goodness knows how many times
and as they will in london they queued
for the chance to file past the coffin
taking their turn for a solemn and
silent show of respect
it was uh quite emotional
i took a big breath before i went in
and then i did a little bow by her
coffin
and to see that it was the scottish
crown on the top was lovely to see
she's
the queen of the scots
she was declared that wasn't she
so she's uh the queen of england but
she's our queen
for her last few hours on scottish soil
it's people saying their farewell greg
milam sky news edinburgh
let's go now to our correspondent emma
birchley who is actually
very near here at buckingham palace uh
looking at the tributes that have
continued to pile up um emma all of the
action supposedly has been in edinburgh
today but actually
um people are still coming here aren't
they
so many people coming here if i step
back you can just
take a look at the site here in green
park it's where people are being told to
bring
the flowers and it's the most
magnificent site and what the pictures
don't do
is give you a sense of the wonderful
smell it's like walking into
a florist's
and
when you look at the flowers you can see
that there is no plastic in sight so
people have been urged to take the
plastic off 700 bags taken away
yesterday
and that's so that
the flowers ultimately can be composted
and quite a nice touch
that compost will then be used to
nourish the soil in the royal parks and
i'm joined now
and by some guests now the first one is
ponce you've come all the way from
washington you're on vacation
what do you make of this here uh well
it's a a great expression of how the
britons and the um visitors
give their respect and condolences to
queen elizabeth the
second
i was surprised when i got off the plane
that she passed away but
i changed my vacation plan and i've been
out here for about three days and
seeing mounds of beautiful flowers and
um is representative of her fashion you
know very colorful and
it's uh
it's a great experience thank you so
much now angie you've come from kent
um what did the queen mean to you
i think she meant so much to the public
and just being here is just absolutely
beautiful it's been really wonderful
seeing all generations from grandmothers
to mothers and children it's a really
family celebration and i think this is
really a celebration of her life and
really being thankful for everything
that she's done for the last 70 years
and it was a beautiful tribute and
seeing it at night time and the flowers
the effort people have made
and the paddington bears and marmalade
sandwiches it's just wonderful thank you
so much i think that's it isn't it a
tribute it's a wonderful feeling pip
you're originally from new zealand but
you live here now
um
what feeling have you had from from the
sense of being here i've been
overwhelmed actually with um just the
scale of the flowers and the colors and
all the flags from the different
countries and the different generations
it's brought grand great grandparents
grandparents and my mother was four
years older than the queen and the queen
was her style icon so i'm recognizing
some of the colors and themes from that
and everybody loved her and
thank you so much for your time
so a really wonderful way of paying
tribute to the queen here and the people
keep on coming
emma thank you very much indeed uh tracy
borman is with me once again um this is
going to be the week of the bear and the
marmalade sandwich isn't it
how important looking back over these
transitions has
public reaction been has it mattered in
the way the transitions work or not it's
really mattered
and i think the example i would draw on
would be that of lady jane grey the nine
days queen the succession was altered in
her favor but the weight of public
opinion was against her you don't
disrupt the royal succession she's
called the nine days queen for a reason
and then you know she was ousted from
the throne by the mass of people now a
more extreme example would be the first
king charles who rode roughshod over the
wishes of his people and his parliament
and of course he paid the ultimate price
with his head during the civil war now
they're extreme examples but i think in
general monarchs ignore public opinion
at their peril and we can see that
public reaction
so graphically now because we've got the
telly everybody's reporting it like no
like nobody's business do you think this
is um
making it easier for the new king
it's a challenge though isn't it um for
him to to keep on top of everything but
at least you know he's very well
informed there's no doubt uh really what
people are thinking that they're showing
what they're thinking certainly in the
numbers that they're turning out for for
the events this week um so yes i think
probably king charles is more aware of
his subject's opinions than any other
monarch in the history of the crown
tracy thank you so much for being with
us and uh
putting all this in in historical
context it's good to remember this is
part of a thousand year story so thank
you so much
all right let's have a look at some of
the events taking place over the next
seven days
tomorrow the king will travel to
northern ireland he'll visit
hillsborough castle
belfast he'll meet the new secretary of
state for northern ireland and party
leaders he'll also receive a message of
condolence led by the speaker of the
northern ireland assembly
in the afternoon the king and the queen
consort will visit sin and cathedral for
a service of prayer and reflection
and after the service they'll leave
belfast and return to london
meanwhile the queen's coffin will be
taken to edinburgh airport and flown
flown to raf northalt it'll then be
transported to buckingham palace by road
and remain here overnight
on wednesday afternoon the king will
lead a procession carrying the coffin to
the palace of westminster where the
archbishop of canterbury will conduct a
short service
the queen's lying in state will then
begin in westminster hall that will last
for four days
on friday the king and queen consort
travel to cardiff where they'll attend a
prayer service they'll meet wales's
first minister
and on sunday evening the night before
the funeral king charles will host a
reception for foreign dignitaries who
are attending
on the morning of monday the 19th of
september the lying in state ends
the queen's coffin will be taken in
procession to westminster abbey for the
state funeral service
let's talk now to someone with great
experience in the political and
constitutional domain
harrod harmon the longest serving female
member of parliament held a number of
senior ministerial roles including
leader of the house of commons and lord
privy seal good evening eric thank you
for joining us
um
what did you
take from this morning's ceremonies when
the king came to the house of parliament
so
it was a very
um
auspicious occasion because it was both
at one and the same time
all the mps of the house of commons and
many many of the members of the house of
lords
formally expressing their condolences
to king charles for the loss of his
mother so that there was that somber
nature of the occasion but also
expressing support
for him as the new king
as his parliament and the relationship
between the monarch
and parliament is a very closely
interwoven one and a very delicate
balance and i think it was very
interesting that he said he would follow
in his mother's footsteps in that he
would support parliament but not
intervene in it
yes that's becoming very clear i made
point earlier on that his speech this
morning and this evening uh at holyrood
are about continuity and whatever you
thought i did before
look to the queen for the model but
what's interesting i think is that
a lot of what you people like you have
been talking about has been the personal
relationship between
parliamentarians and the sovereign and
you indeed had your own story i think
about uh the
the queen's kindness to you and that
seems to be
a very important part of this
relationship it's not just what's
written down in paper it's the actual
human relationship that matters well the
monarch has a formal role so we would
have like the queen's speech where she
would do the state opening of parliament
and we would vote on bills but they
wouldn't become law until she'd signed
them with the royal assent
but actually there was a lot of behind
the scenes interconnection as well we've
heard a lot about the weekly visits of
the prime minister to have audiences
with the queen and the advice and
support that she has given them over the
decades but as well there was a close
relationship between the queen and
ministers not just that you go up to the
palace when you're appointed and given
your great seals of office to take home
and put in the department safe as you're
appointed a minister of the crown but
also if as in my case you get sacked you
get invited up to the palace or at least
i was invited up to the palace to have
tea with the queen for her to thank me
for my service and that was just a very
private thing so she didn't make it
known there was no proclamation about it
it was just private support and i think
that's what's important she did the
ceremonial work but she also did
all that private work and support and i
think what you've seen
is 70 years worth of credit and respect
that has been built up
it's not just the office it's the way
she carried out that role
and therefore it can't just be
continuity for king charles he will have
to build that support himself because
this is about personal relationships and
how you do the job how you carry out
that role but also in a very changed
world so he
he did the reassurance but he will
inevitably need to change it and of
course one thing that is different is we
did have a woman modder
with a a male consort
and with a male consort i think prince
philip had
really no option but just to say very
little because if he did everybody think
what does he think does he think he's
wearing the crown no it's her whereas
there is a much more accepted role for a
queen consort and i think that will mean
queen camilla will be able to carry on
doing the work that she has been doing
very successfully with women's
organizations such as on osteoporosis
and domestic violence well i i was going
to ask you about i you know i couldn't
have mother parliament here not ask
about that um
one thing that it's i think it's very
interesting is the emergence
as significant independent figures of
women in the royal family you've
mentioned the queen consort particularly
her work on domestic abuse which is a
kind of a risky area i think uh the
print new princess of wales was
you know
uh is probably the single most popular
member of the royal family the duchess
of wessex sophie thought to be the
queen's closest uh confidant and um the
princess royal also actually emerging it
is said as her brother's uh closest
advisor
what do you think that tells us the fact
that
women are playing such a prominent role
in the royal story today in a way i
think would not have been
true a generation ago
and they all seem to be doing a very
good job and we feel as if we can have
confidence in them you know this current
uh generation of uh of women in the
royal family have been doing a lot of
good work and not been putting their
foot in it and i think that
queen console camilla
has already done a lot of work and
whilst
king charles has said that he's going to
have to give up some of his charities i
would hope and expect that she that that
queen consult camilla won't give up
that charitable work that she will still
carry on supporting those organizations
which so appreciate her advocacy so
hopefully she'll be able to do that as
well as being a supporter of um the king
to which she's referred very warmly on
every occasion yeah so i think she he's
been pretty clear that he will rest on
her support but that she is in some
senses an independent uh figure in in
what will probably be a slimmed down
monarchy do you think um
what would you say is going to be
his hallmark
when he thinks about modernization of
the monarchy
well i'm afraid i just wouldn't know
that and can't speculate but i think
that he will have to take the best of
what the queen did and then make it fit
for a modern age but it will remain the
fact that the monarchy
is the foundation on which not just our
country but our constitutional democracy
is built and therefore getting that
relationship right from the outset with
parliament will be really important but
i think because of the goodwill that the
queen had generated visiting it seems
like all of the 650 constituencies
countless times you heard the speeches
in the house of commons she had opened
so many swimming pools inaugurated so
many bridges attended so many scout
groups she must have been the woman that
knew every corner of this country better
than anybody and that built up that
relationship and he will have to
you know in double quick time do the
same
hard harmon thank you very much indeed
now our royal correspondent rhiannon
mills joins me once again from edinburgh
um rhiannon another busy day tomorrow
can you take us through the plan for
tomorrow
it was interesting there hearing harriet
hartmann talk about how the new king
will need to reach out to
every corner of the united kingdom and
we're going to see that continue
uh tomorrow he is going to stay here in
edinburgh tonight but then in the
morning we'll travel to to belfast
he will go to hillsborough castle he
will also then
listen to another motion of condolence
and beat political figures
in northern ireland he'll also view
an exhibition related to the queen's
relationship and closeness
to northern ireland and i think again
it's it's tallying in really with that
sense of
having to be seen to be believed that of
course was so important to the queen and
today in scotland we've seen a great
deal of that things like the fact that
he did a walkabout
before going into the palace of
hollyrood house that was completely
unexpected
but that sense of wanting to to share
this moment with as many people as
possible
make that connection and also
of course he then also went into into
the parliament here um but i think what
is going to be a hugely significant
moment tomorrow is uh the fact that he
will again i think try and open up the
process to everybody of what is going on
it's taken a very long time but sorry
it's been a very short time in fact
since everything has had to change
and i think in terms of making sure that
people
understand the ceremony understand
what's going on that's really important
in terms of making sure that the the
royal family can continue to connect in
the way that the queen
always wanted them to and that of course
is happening tonight as people are
streaming and past her coffin at st jars
cathedral and tomorrow i think probably
the most moving picture that we will see
um of the day tomorrow is the queen of
course is going to leave scotland for
one final time she's going to be flown
down to raf northolt then transferred in
a hearse to buckingham palace and we'll
enter through the gates there for the
final time literally three months
since we saw her appearing on the
balcony at buckingham palace for her
platinum jubilee so the crowds there who
are gathering close to you trevor will
finally
see the queen returning there to
buckingham palace
rhiannon thank you very much indeed
let's reflect now on the significance of
the past few days i'm joined by dame
linda colley professor of history at
princeton
university good evening uh linda thank
you so much for taking your time
looking at this
visit to scotland
what do you think the challenge for the
new monarch is when it comes to the
union
well
i mean this is such a sad period but
it's also in some ways a holiday period
because of course it takes people away
from the normal pressing political and
economic issues which are still waiting
there in the background
and
one of the issues is of course uh
tension between the different parts of
the united kingdom
uh i think a constitutional monarch
can help smooth
some of these tensions
but in the end he
charles iii is a constitutional monarch
it will come down to the politics and it
will come down to the people's will of
course
but he's obviously making uh
a very serious point of going to
obviously he's in scotland tonight he
will go to northern ireland tomorrow he
will be in wales later in the week and
um there's clearly a conscious effort
here to reach out isn't there
do you think
that
has any impact at all on if you like the
political environment in which as you
say politicians have to sort it out but
do you think that sort of thing will
make any difference to the environment
in which they have to work
well you know everything
helps
i'm a supporter of the union though it
needs reform in different ways
and
i think one of the
strengths of the monarchy which it's
increasingly stressed really from the
beginning of the 19th century
is its ability to a degree to a degree
to
tie together
the different component parts of the uk
because um it's a very
attractive image if you like i mean if
you're a monarchist if you believe in
the crown but people can respond to
people
in ways that they can't respond
necessarily to institutions
so
by being able to visit different parts
of the uk which of course is is much
easier in the early 21st century with
the transport facilities we've got
monarchs can
play this
really rather important personal role
and i'm sure charles iii will try and do
that too
um this question of the union is is part
of a wider issue a rider question i
guess about british identity and uh i
think it's probably fair to say that you
wrote the book literally as well as uh
figuratively speaking on that
idea of modern british identity
what do you think that the new king
has to do
to engage with the challenge of defining
what it should feel like what it should
look like what it should seem like to be
british in the 21st century
well i think it's got to be part of a
much wider process of reinvention if
it's to work at all
i mean in a sense
the late monarch queen elizabeth ii
came to her throne at a fortunate time
the country was still recovering from
the war
but it had a wonderful story
that it had stood strong against nazi
germany it had not been invaded
um it had fought successfully and so on
uh and that was very important
and of course there was still the
residual sense of a global power still
in a way that the uk no longer is
um
king charles has got a rather
more difficult brief to speak to i think
uh and
how far he is successful will depend as
i say on a wider
uh effort of creating a new legend a new
narrative
for a uk of the 21st century
and how do we do that
um i think the monarchy can play a part
in that
well
of course great great leaders and kings
sovereigns of all kinds uh
tell their people a story of one kind or
another now i i don't know if it is
still the case that um historians uh
essentially come in are summoned to
advise the sovereign on that sort of
story i i know uh in various points in
the past that has been the practice but
um if
you were asked what what is the sort of
legend as you put it what is the kind of
narrative what is the modern story that
you would draw
for
britain today that the prince sorry the
king
should be thinking about
well um
i think the capacity to change
uh which you might think is a a strange
uh legend to come from a monarch
who is often seen of in in terms of
tradition
but in fact that the the uk has
to a degree
managed to cope with a great deal of
change since the second world war
while remaining
uh reasonably stable
and that's
that's quite a considerable story uh
given all the other uh
things that are happening in the world
at large so i think that mixture of
stability with quite radical change in
all sorts of ways i mean it's a
far more diverse population in the uk
than it was at the end of the second
world war it's a much less differential
population of course
um there's all sorts of new challenges
so
that balance of um
being willing and able to change
and
maintaining some kind of cohesion
that's something that um i think the
monarch can
can help with
and just very briefly if you had to pick
out uh this this point that uh queen
elizabeth has in the sense given us the
sense of a story of stability while
presiding over great change if you had
to pick out one great change that's
could be identified between
1952 and now what would it be
ah
so many but um
i suppose one change would be
um the very different role of women
um you know the fact that the
the current prime minister is actually
the third female prime minister in uk
history
uh well that that
but that i mean that's a that is a great
point i'm so sorry i've got to
draw it to a close now but i think
that is pretty clear thank you so much
professor linda colley
pleasure
the queen's death has been a cause for
grief across the country and even those
of a less than ardent royalist 10
decency has spoken warmly of her life of
service
there are some who believe that the
automatic transition of sovereignty to a
new head of state is undemocratic and
think that the very idea of monarchy is
an absurd anachronism
so much could perhaps have been
predicted but the police have been
criticized for what some see as a
heavy-handed approach to those who have
voiced those sentiments in a public
setting
our home editor jason farrell reports
now on the right to protest
the man circled here is heckling prince
andrew during the procession of the
queen's coffin through edinburgh
in response many drowned him out
chanting god save the king
then someone in the crowd decided they'd
had enough
[Applause]
on the pavement behind the crowd police
try to calm the situation as tempers
or republican most will consider this a
time to reflect on an incredible life of
service but some will want the queen's
passing to signal the end of the
institution itself and make themselves
heard
[Music]
in response to protesters police have
either moved people on or in some
instances made arrests two people in
edinburgh have been charged
so i called out who elected him
after saying that at a proclamation of
the king in oxford on sunday simon hill
was handcuffed and detained by the
police are we really now in a place in
21st century britain where a new head of
state is proclaimed uh we're told to
accept this person without without any
question and somebody who speaks out
against it is
he is dragged off and arrested it felt
like a
like i'd slipped into the 16th century
for a minute
policing events leading up to the
queen's funeral is a large and complex
operation and there are new laws around
protests
the police crime sentencing and courts
act which became law this year gives
police more powers to disrupt protests
if they're deemed to be causing
significant harm to those nearby
interpretation of that depends on the
circumstances and the sensitivities and
the complication here is we have two
things happening at once a moment of
national mourning but also the
proclamation of a new king a big
constitutional change
well this is absolutely the time to talk
about the future of the monarchy because
we have a pneumonic and
you know charles has become king without
consent without discussion or debate
it's just happened automatically
and there is
no effort to have a serious debate about
that and that is completely wrong
but people coming to pay their respects
in windsor say this isn't the week for
it
they wouldn't do it would they if the
lady down the road died would they
yeah so you're talking about the monarch
of this country has been around for 70
years
i think that's just disrespectful some
people might be saying well they're
protesting against the new king not
against them well i think i think at the
end of the day
whoever it is
you know whether it's politics or in
royalty give them a chance
i don't think should be arrested i'd
probably just totally ignore them
this hereditary transfer of power is
something we've not seen in 70 years
it's bound to have a mixed reception
several protest groups have said they
won't campaign during this time of
mourning but some will and it's the
police in the first instance he'll have
to decide what is and isn't appropriate
jason farrell sky news
that's all for this special program
coming up next is news at 10 with dermot
monaghan here at buckingham palace and
anna botting in edinburgh
you